did you feel like he was like nothing
did you sort of before because like i
mean you look at
you know you're an amazing shape
work out got it together strong
blah blah blah you know they always say
be careful the
the the people who are you know
pre-existing conditions which
obviously if that that's that could be
deadly with you
did you really think you were ever going
to get it were you one of those people
like
you think i'm just not going to get it
i'm not going to get this oh
i always knew that it was a possibility
number one
and i felt a great deal of pressure to
not
get it and this is something that i got
into once i got a positive test
um you know a lot of a lot of the mental
fear but to answer this to answer this
question first
i've always been really good about about
mask wearing
about social distancing um
just following the rules you know not
going
not going to uh not going to a huge
house party or
or or concert or whatever you know
yeah or like super large super large
gatherings where people aren't wearing
masks
but i haven't been
i also haven't been totally afraid
of it which i know cert which i know
certain people are
and certain people have the absolute
right to be
whether you have a pre-existing
condition whether you're whether you're
elderly um you know my mom is not
elderly per se but
um i think that she's a little
frightened of it because you know she's
had
a met she's had a medical history and
you know you just don't know
it's scary yeah people are dying for it
from it uh for me
honestly because it was called cobit
i've had
i've had to be where i've been for the
past
three weeks since the past i was
actually released from quarantine this
past
friday but you quarantined to be before
you even get went on heels to start
filming
you had to quarantine for two weeks once
you landed in atlanta correct
i had to warn you for two weeks once we
landed in canada because we went to
canada in the summer when we got to
georgia
everyone has to self-isolate for for
five days
and then we get tested monday wednesday
friday
um and these aren't rapid result
tests um but i mean you're getting them
at
if you test positive you're getting a
phone call at you know six
seven o'clock the next morning otherwise
you're just getting an email that
says you know says negative so maybe
there was a part of me that was starting
to feel a little invincible because
i mean by the time i tested positive
we're looking at
gosh 40 negative tests
and what are you doing this time you're
just on set you're not going gallivading
gallivanting around you're not no right
so
who did you get it from do you have an
idea of who gave it to you
no i don't um
i have absolutely no idea
how it happened um you know i was
i was out for dinner uh in georgia but i
i i did i did my own contact tracing on
that
one and not finding any
not finding any evidence that you know
it happened it happened
you know then and there is there a
relief to it is there a relief that you
have it and you're just like now i have
the antibodies and now
it's almost like oh there's because
here's also there is now
except there wasn't when it happened the
the the most difficult
part about it and one of the reasons
that i want to talk about it right now
is is what whether or not
you're you're frightened of it there is
a lot of fear-mongering
going on about it and there's a lot of
there's a lot of conjecture and there's
a lot of people
that are you know
basically trying to scare the [ __ ] out
of you a little bit
because when it happened and when i got
the positive test
for me it became holy [ __ ]
i just destroyed this show because i've
never worn on the call sheet
and i work every day give her more or
less
i say like four and a half days a week
on this first block that we were
shooting
and i'm in my head going [ __ ]
they're gonna have to shut down the
production um
you know we're we're not yet done the
first block
of two episodes um you know did i just
did i just ruin this that's the first
thing you're thinking of not am i going
to die
no no i no i wasn't worried about that
there is there is a little bit of a
mental struggle because one of the
things you hear about
is you hear about the you hear that
the symptoms can be mild at the start
you can feel
better and then there's a relapse
and things come back and when they come
back they come back worse than before
um you know thankfully that that
didn't happen to me but it's
there's a real malaise that sets in
you